a little blood here checking in Y'all
Gonna tweak on my interview with the
bootleg cab podcast man some dope going
on and you might find out how real or
fake Kev is
bootleg cat podcast we got a special
guest in here
all the way from the bay we're not too
far away Oakland Oakland is in the
building low blood welcome West Oakland
to be exact now this is what's crazy is
I have and I'm pretty like
like I would say I'm like pretty tapped
in with the Bay Area Music I guess I'm
not all the way tapped in because I kind
of found you off of your interviews I
forgot I think I was talking to uh
I was talking to somebody I was talking
to Russell uh-huh and I was like yeah
like little bloody this dope he's got a
dope platform he's like oh you don't
know from from his his record that went
crazy I was like nah bro right so I kind
of came came like up on you like in
terms of just like you interviewing
people and you having like a dope
platform right right
um thank you I appreciate it and um I'm
glad I started that platform because
that got me indoors that normally
wouldn't have been open from the music
right but uh [__] happens and it runs
hand in hand but now my music career
fires like um no I've been tapped it
tapping in and checking out your [__]
because I followed you and then
um the third world record was the record
yeah yeah when a super viral so it's
crazy uh
we recorded that record like 10 years
ago and um it was just on some uh my one
of my partners bolski had went to jail
and um we was hella Maddie went to jail
and at that time
um
do you remember little basically of
course isn't The [__] Mob record the
same beat so yeah so what happened was
you know we we big little B fans me too
I used to cook [__] Ellen DeGeneres
yeah like yeah so
um
he used to always come by singing that
song and when boski went to jail we like
[__] it we just recorded the record but
we was playing around bullshitting with
the record and um for the record it's
not mixed or Master like you know so
many Bay Classics are not mixing Masters
yeah it happens it happens a lot shout
out to Dilo like no hope sounds like it
just they just laid it down and dropped
that [__] but I think Ozzie said he
mixed no gazi said he I think it was
NoHo or um the record with tiger Dilo
one of them that one probably got mixed
in yeah but um long story short [__] we
recorded that song Bam and it's always
been like a northern California hit
right but um I don't know what happened
on Tick Tock that [__] just went crazy
it's been going crazy recently right
yeah it's still going crazy like I don't
know you don't know the source of like
who who posted this source of who posted
it I think it was uh
I don't know some little dude did a
dance to it long story short that [__]
went fire and it's still going and God
is good it's got to be crazy because I
was like you'll see like old records pop
up and he'll be like damn but that goes
to show you music is timeless for sure
even just like having an independent hit
go like resurface right hell yeah that's
like different like oh yeah um and um
the crazy part about it is uh
it went viral didn't stop didn't it go
viral again like it keeps you know doing
that [__] like Kim Kardashian and
Northwest so I was seeing hella like
um Aries and Jada and them doing [__] to
us so I'm like oh that's cool I go
um but when I seen Kim K in Northwest do
it wild yeah I'm like okay that's
different Kanye paying attention I mean
I hope so yeah definitely yeah
definitely yeah no [__] well [__] and
that's independently you that's straight
into business right independent yeah for
sure
records don't do that
um so for you like fast forward now
having that kind of happen and having
people kind of come into your catalog
and check out like the newer [__] like
where are you on the music side because
you're so you're doing so much you're
obviously Community leader you're
obviously doing the podcast and still
dropping new music how do you balance
the [__] balance yeah
um
honestly it's the same [__] so uh
with our studio we have a studio where
we film our podcast we also got a
recording studio there you get what I'm
saying so and then it's like I was
popping away with the music way before
the podcast and [__] I just started
doing the podcast and [__] because my
team shout out talker media shout out
bear Jones they works like bro you going
on all these people platforms and you're
blowing that [__] up like people love to
hear you talk right bro start doing your
own [__] right and they was telling me
this for damn near a year or two before
I said [__] it come on let's try it and
then one day we did it in front of the
first episode people gravitated towards
it and then I had um the people that
reach out like bro I want to come on
your podcast I want to sit down with you
when you sitting at your house at four
in the morning and Marshawn Lynch call
you and like bro what the [__] bro why
you ain't telling me you had a podcast
he just talked he just came on the
second time right yeah yeah yeah yeah he
just did it a second time and it's just
like you know people like that and just
talk like bro I rather sit down with you
because [__] [__] you fed a call
you're the culture right [__] you ain't
trying to make no money you ain't
vulture you ain't asking no weird ass
questions you not I'm you're not gonna
have a blood on your podcast or ask them
why they Funk with Crips you know you
get what I'm saying like that [__] just
sterile so I'm like [__] I might as well
keep this [__] going so that's what made
me just drop that [__] in low and push
the [__] out the podcast yeah well how
often do you drop is it once a week
um no sometimes it depends like
um sometimes I drop three or four a week
it depends sometimes I won't drop
nothing for two weeks it depends on how
we feeling so um it been days to wear
and they got into eight interviews and
one day got there got to our uh Studio
probably before and we ain't leaving the
three or four in the morning type [__]
and then waking up and being back there
at 12 again like you know I feel like
too it was like a needed uh void filled
in the bay yeah to have like a dope
platform obviously I think if you come
to La you got guys like 80 and T well
doing their thing right you know shout
out uh t-rail he uh put me on a no
jumper salute too real for that I
remember that interview yeah that was
one of the early uh t-rell interviews
yeah
um no honestly it was the last interview
they did in that day before they left oh
in the old building though it was in the
old building yeah yeah shout out to real
for that and like I said uh Tyrell was
on there early you know all his homies I
[__] with LA a lot like bro you gotta
get blood on your [__] you gotta get
blood on your [__] you interviewing all
these [__] like you gotta get blood on
your [__] like you know blood really he
really pushed this [__] and when he rap
about he really is that so grab him on
your [__] and when he reached out you
know it's all salute to Tyrell he did it
I just think it's dope too because like
you always will hear that like the bay
doesn't get enough credit and that's
true in terms of influence in terms of
culture in terms of just everything that
they brought to the game and me and
Ghazi always have these conversations
about like how back in the day there was
so much music industry in San Francisco
in the Bay Area you had Jive Records Was
there and you had a lot of a lot of
people would have offices around the
city and I guess like what's kind of
missing is like representation of media
right on a bigger scale right right
um so I think it's dope to like you saw
that like hey I'ma just do this [__]
myself you know definitely and uh like I
said with my [__] um
like I just feel like my [__] is is
authentic bro like my [__] is pure like
I don't get people on my [__] and acts
trying to stir [__] out start [__] I'm
not looking for no viral moment right
like I always tell people all the time
my viral moment is what we sitting there
building and we having a conversation
and you may say some [__] that somebody
is going through you get what I'm saying
and that might spark a flame in them to
change their life or they probably was
thinking about suicide and they didn't
commit suicide because they looking at
okay damn if little blood going through
this [__] you feel me and this is how
you handle it I can get over this [__]
too so that's my final moment I ain't
looking for no click bait we don't do
clickbait we don't do none of that [__]
I might drop an interview and the [__]
don't do no numbers you feel me but the
shorter take off right yeah yes for sure
the real or the shorter yeah so all
right I'm doing my job bro like I said
I'm not on that fake [__] we don't do
that at talking media we don't
um push [__] we you know we
articulture and we're not trying to gain
off the culture and we're not trying to
exploit the culture you get what I'm
saying for sure man I think I I that's
what I think I told I think uh one of
the like I think the Russell interview I
saw you do was just incredible I was
like this [__] is dope thank you
Marshawn shoulders though I didn't see
the new Marshawn
um interview but obviously we just
filmed it we haven't dropped the [__]
it'd be very hard for anybody to get the
Marshawn Lynch interview
[Laughter]
or man there's other one the second one
like I said that's like
um that's brother you know at the end of
the day uh you know we help each other
like from the fan first shout out fam
first shout out Josh Johnson shout out
Marcus Peters shout out all them guys
over there at fam first it's like a
family thing you know I'm I'm doing um
fundraisers I'm helping them uh with
talent shows or you know whatever it is
maybe what date doing I'm in full
support of it so whatever I do they are
in full support of it and it's all the
way love type [__] for people who don't
know obviously we like to lump in
Northern California together a lot
people will even like who don't know
better say think mozzy's from the bay no
he's from Sacramento he's from
Sacramento but everyone just loves to
hold but shout out Mozzy a lot of bait
[__] won't say this because they
cornballs but uh what Mazzy did shed a
lot of light on the bay too for sure
yeah so salute Mozzy that's yeah for
sure I was gonna say though being from
Oakland obviously Oakland is kind of
like the flavor of the area in my
opinion open is the mecca of California
if you ask me so kind of break down like
coming from Oakland what is the
difference between in your opinion like
because I feel like Oakland
and Vallejo Loki have kind of
historically popped more than artists
from San Francisco obviously burner's
dope uh the 24 Karat golden kid just
went platinum I think
um but but like breakdown like why you
say it's the epicenter of culture and
why Oakland is just different from
everywhere else um you have to realize
um
so
let's go back historically
black panthers right uh that movement
sparked a worldwide change you get what
I'm saying
um from what the Panthers did
um let's say the Crips for example day
literature
help you know start that not saying that
the Black Panther started that but that
literature with the Black Panthers was
pushing the Crips organization started
off that you get what I'm saying
um black panthers they reaching what
they stuff what they stood for was so
dope they had
um chapters in Chicago and New York and
um
they did so much and then it's like the
game like um
let's say the pimping at home the Mac
was filmed in Oakland like you get what
I'm saying they had to come to where
that [__] was real like you get what I'm
saying they filmed the whole Mac in
Oakland um let's start from the crack
the dope era like one of the first
places in the world that sold crack
cocaine was Oakland you get what I'm
saying um Oakland just on some positive
[__] um look at the uh the athletes that
came out of Oakland
um the uh I think it was Bill Russell
just a lot of flavor just comes from
that little city you get what I'm saying
and I think it's because of look
kill me if I'm wrong right so when um
was it Eldritch Cleaver I think it was
Elders Cleaver when eldris clever was
running for mayor of Oakland
it was Bobby seals I think one of them
two Eldridge or Bobby it was one of them
when they was running for Mayors when he
was running for mayor of Oakland right
all these brothers these Smart Sharp
individuals from all these uh chapters
of the Black Panthers from Chicago New
York the South all these brothers
descended on Oakland to help push him
into that right this is like the 70s 60s
70s they all came to Oakland to help
push and get people to vote go
door-to-door so but when all these
brothers coming they sending their best
Brothers they sending um the top
Scholars the top gang spitters the top
whatever it is in in your field they
sending all these top Brothers on
Oakland and guess what these [__] was
doing when they coming they [__] our
[__] they having babies by these hoes
you feel me crazy yeah and what that was
doing is like I said these are top game
spinners top people from that genre they
[__] these [__] they uh doing all
type of [__] and um boom from their
babies they was having our parents and
[__] like that and just all this good
gang was just in this gumbo boxes
soaking up and [__] like that so Oakland
is so different and so like even
Immaculate in so many different areas
like um
how we talk we shake California
um the way we dress like I remember when
[__] when you seen a [__] with dreads
and gold teeth are they from Oakland you
get what I'm saying now everybody you
see a [__] with dreads yeah we talking
about on this side
yeah you see a [__] with um you
know certain [__] hot [__] talk
what's up with my partner man you know
what I'm saying all right the lingo like
okay that [__] from Oakland he slicked
in the [__] now everybody
talking like that everybody got some
type of gimmick or some Gander to run so
Oakland is the mecca of all that [__]
for sure
um who are some of the artists out of
Oakland right now that you uh want to
shed some light on that might be doing
their thing ah man I really hate people
outside of yourself always miss people
that's fair man I really hate it who you
working with
um in Oakland right now me for sure I'm
always push my [__] you feel me the uh
little goofies the beezies the Momos
imma always push my [__] but
um Oakland I want to say the whole
Oakland bro because
um
what Oakland is doing right now and I'm
seeing this shift it used to be hella
political it's still political as [__]
but um Oakland is starting to embrace
Oak to embrace Oakland you get what I'm
saying like they're starting to support
each other and um and the reason why I
don't like singling our names and [__]
because you know there'd be somebody
watching this interview like uh he said
this [__] and them [__] [__] with
this [__] new [__] right you get what
I'm saying so I'm just gonna share
inadvertently
it's going to right I mean so shout out
to East shout out to North shout out the
west and you know it's [__] from all
through Oakland that's doing their [__]
right now for sure do you feel like um
there's any sort of because it feels
like the the base having a moment where
we might start to kind of like
see like I feel like guys like symbols
from Antioch uh obviously Russell's from
Vallejo
um the boys dope I think I don't know if
the boy just got locked up again or not
I think so I think
but it feels like there's a lot of just
high level energy and interest
nationally when it comes to like some of
these artists like you'll see Russell
going on a lot of these big platforms
you'll see a guy like LeBron James
reposting a Simba freestyle like do you
because I mean I think back to the hyphy
era and like that moment kind of
captivated the country and I feel like
that was kind of the last time that
happened yeah because I think it was uh
my ghetto report card you know yeah I
think it was misrepresented wrong I was
having this conversation with Mr Fab not
too long ago like [__] that kind of uh
in fact my brother you feel me man Fab
talk [__] all the time and um I was
telling them the high fee era was cool
but it made us look Boosie in a sense
because people thought that was all we
were doing right you give me uh popping
pills and dancing outside the car again
I was part of it that was the
they was talking about that [__] like
right we were doing at that time like
yeah that dancing part that's cool but
[__] what about these [__] that's
hustling what about these [__] that's
hitting neither selling dope in the
kitchen whipping that [__] with both
hands like
what we were going through at that time
and what we were doing it wasn't
highlighted that's why it was easy for
Jeezy and Gucci to take off because they
was speaking that [__] that was going on
in that in that time frame you feel me
[__] styling and jackers and the Shady
notes they were speaking that [__] too
but it was overpowered by the Ghost
Rider whip [__] right you get what I'm
saying so uh
yeah and like I said a lot of them cast
that was hella dope in that era Mr
streaming error by you know or they were
like a little early like I feel like the
pack was like literally before I think
little B was before oh for sure but I
mean the pack like if you think about
like sonically what they were doing you
fast forward a few years and then like
Rack City happens and right right yeah
and it's almost like oh that was kind of
very sonically similar to right to what
the pack was doing years ago yeah and I
think um even like fashion wise they had
pink dolphins right and I think people
won't say it I think um
the AL that La sound at that time was
heavily Bay of influence I say it all
the time yeah like rest in peace to the
great tracks a million like right that
sound he was creating I hear that a lot
in mustard you know what I'm saying yeah
I've said it a bunch right I'm always
like hey let's forget what the pack was
doing what a lot of these guys in the
bay were doing right right right right
hey how important for you because like I
always I I feel like there's a guy like
uh G-Eazy right who probably
commercially outside of MC hammers run
is probably like commercially
like the biggest guy to represent the
Bay right I'm not talking about
influence or or tenure yeah I just mean
like you know representation yeah yeah I
understand geez got Souls of Britney
Spears and right um but he was like very
adamant about every tour was like from
the bait of the universe and he would
bring like I am Sue or he would bring
keilani on the road right he would bring
40 on the road
um how like like how big in the
landscape of the bay do you look at like
a guy like G and like you know it seemed
like he was doing a lot to try to do his
best to give back
um shout outs is easy salute to G-Eazy
um I don't have no apology easy good
thing is is um
that's 40. yeah that's kailani look at
the names you name but it was keilani
was it was it was like early K line okay
okay
for sure all black all black he did all
black I just finished Netflix on the
road with him a lot I just feel as if uh
you should embrace that more you get
what I'm saying not uh like I said not
just
um let [__] smooch off you but Embrace
that [__] more like you know
do more of that you get what I'm saying
like do more of that like salute to you
what you got going on but do more of
that so you would like to see him do
more yeah for sure [__] yeah right [__]
yeah hell yeah but and then too it's
different genres like
he make more music like on soon he's got
pop pop music pop house music type [__]
yeah I don't know how to spell yeah pop
he's got pop records what is house music
anyway
like house music what the [__] is that
it's a genre of electronic music uh
whatever yeah he got that
house is not technical but it's the he
don't make house music but he makes top
40 more he does have top 40 records for
sure yeah yes you know right yeah
I hear it sounds like um I never like
heard of G-Eazy album but right like to
[__] with me and get some money all that
type of [__] right let me put all black
on a record yeah you know yeah for sure
for sure uh Black's dope as [__] too
super dope super dope yeah for sure I
like um
all black Cadence and [__] he be
different with that [__] for you like
um what is like your like I know you
you've been dropping like tell me kind
of what's going on with your music [__]
right now like what's the latest what's
coming from the last project I put out
was the book of dialogue it did uh it
did very well but
um I had got over powered by the little
Blood TV type [__] right you get what
I'm saying um and I was just telling my
boys like damn I need to jump back in
the lab right like uh because I've been
focusing so much on this and it haven't
had me in the studio mode I mean I can
go to the studio and record a song
that's not that's crazy but I'm saying
in that artist now where you're like
fully engaged and you're yeah yeah and
you just like you in that space to
record and I tell people all the time
it's a difference from
um
it's a difference from rapping and just
being in that in that space right I'm
saying you could go write a verse if
someone wanted to buy a birth office you
go knock that out I can go do that in 10
minutes but if you want to like put out
an album
I'm working with the mechanics have you
ever heard of them yeah I've heard of
them yeah yeah shout out to uh dot dot
and tweet for Rex and tweet I'm working
with them right now we uh been in the
lab for like the last couple of months
and we got a great sounding project like
I'm hella excited about this project
because every time I went in the studio
I was in the studio mode you were like
locked in I was locked in and um
sometimes [__] will be in there for six
seven hours and just do a song and a
half are you writing [__] down yeah yeah
right yeah yeah all right and uh you
know because you know the new the new
the whole new era is all punching in
it's punching in I do I do that
sometimes too but this project I'm
writing I feel like if you're gonna do a
Melody it's like smart to do the melody
first then you kind of fill in the lines
yeah if you're gonna do a verse you know
I think punching in to get you lazy
because sometimes you'll just be like
okay let me hurry up and rhyme this with
that and you get what I'm saying there's
not as much thought as yeah when you
write write it down yeah you like you
all you tweaked out you hiked out like
yeah yeah for sure I would prefer
writing over punching it I wish more
rappers were like that yeah I prefer
right because you hear it
because you'll hear guys who say they
write and you'll hear it you'll be like
oh I hear like you're actually every
line matters a little more right but
look though I had got so caught up in
punching in to when I write I'll have to
take blood I couldn't wrap the whole 16.
like I had to rap like four bars and
then start a breath like what the [__]
right right so I had to retrain myself
to get back in there because normally I
can write [__] I used to do 30
something bars like a whole song I can
guess a whole song just reading it like
you know yep but that punching in [__]
that [__] [__] you up anyways yeah yeah
it kind of fuss with you I think it
might be affecting people's performing
too definitely definitely you're you'll
see artists the new artists they'll do
like a part of their verse and then
they'll let the track do the rest right
right right it's the same [__] you don't
have the breath control because they
don't have to do that [__] in the studio
anymore so have you ever heard of the
hieroglyphics of course I love Hyrule
okay um shout out to casual casual my
boy and um casual was telling me uh
while I was performing at Hyrule day and
uh the music My lyrics were playing
behind you feel me it's like [__]
that's [__] like oh yeah that that
would definitely be some like OG
backpack rapper [__] to say
never supposed to rap like that like
but now everybody does it yeah for sure
for sure or you gotta have the TV track
where like parts of the verse are in
there or you're out yeah I will yeah
that's better but I understand what he
meant by that like just rapping over
your voice and it sounds way better when
you're just rapping over the
instrumental yeah it sounds like you're
at a show it sounds like you had a show
for sure for sure for sure yeah shout
out to Hyrule man they kind of
revolutionized a lot on it and they're
from Oakland too and they did so much on
the merch side yeah yeah and still doing
it um I think Souls of Mischief they
just got like a [__] crazy tour 300
[__] shows or something yeah they got
they they could tour I mean Dell shout
out to Dell was Dale from Oakland I
don't know how funky what's your name
tell the funky homicide yeah I think I
think so I think he's from Oakland yeah
yeah shout out to Hyrum so yeah we got
some cash from Oakland man I'm getting
it for sure for sure no two shorts and
you know oh like two shorts my [__]
one of my favorites ever so yeah we got
some cash from Oakland for sure Tony
Tony we got cats from Oakland
um what's up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good friends at my bookie that's
right it is NBA Finals you gotta Hammer
the Nuggets I don't know they might
sweep the the heat I would look at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus
all right look I don't care where you're
at you can go to mybookie.ag Let's
gamble on some sports they got the
casino you can do live Blackjack you can
do live roulette craps you could do all
kinds of slots and of course bet on the
NBA Finals bet on the NHL uh Stanley Cup
finals crazy shots of the Vegas golden
knights that's what I'm rooting for and
of course baseball season man all right
so look right now mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg uh and sign up when
you do use uh that promo code they're
going to give you a first deposit bonus
straight to your account free money all
right mybookie.ag go do that also gotta
give a shout out to our family at Blue
chew that's right ladies and gentlemen
it's getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uhboochu.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself boucher.com
promo code bootleg uh now if you don't
know what it is it is the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form and you do not have to go
to a doctor's appointment all right you
do everything online you don't have to
go sit at a doctor's office and talk to
some old man in a lab coat about your
dick issues not necessary anymore in
2023 all right so go to Bluetooth sign
up with that promo code bootleg get a
month supply for free let's get back to
the interviews yo give me your rundown
on how not to get bipped into Bay
how do we not get it we go visit the bay
how do I not get bit
um first off don't stop by no gas
stations by the airport okay
um never do that
um don't be getting out your car and
putting [__] in the trunk
don't do that don't leave anything and
when I say anything don't leave nothing
at all in your car like don't leave a
charger don't leave [__]
um me personally I crack my windows
um
so you'll you'll you'll let you'll be
like windows are down yeah why not take
a peek if you want I crack my windows um
yeah but for the most part just don't
have [__] in your cars and then you know
I I know how to look for bippers when
I'm pulling up and [__] like I can spot
the bippers and I damn never know [__]
like they see me getting out the car and
[__] like [__] respect enough not to
bit my car also like don't rent a car
rentals you're gonna get your rental you
don't get your ass bit like no matter
what yeah cause people be stupid not no
matter what but people just be stupid
like
why is you leaving backpacks in the car
like I just think people don't know I
just had so my dad is like going to San
Francisco with my sister and my mom
and I had to give him the rundown I said
whatever you do
and I said if you're going to Denny's
take everything with you into Denny's
and then not overnight too because I
know people that follow you and then
stop out that red light while you're at
that red light while you're at the red
light they'll bip you bro and get what
yeah I'm saying but there's that viral
video there was like a split in the
freeway yeah that was serious as [__]
yeah all the time and they took
everything out and then hit the hit the
I said damn yeah but that happens more
that was just caught on camera that [__]
happens daily like you know like you'll
be in the car
yeah but you're supposed to be paying
attention anyway looking in your mirrors
and [__] like why do you think that
that's like a prevalent thing in the
band not enough like it happens in L.A
but it's like a thing in San Francisco
it's just like flocking is a thing in
L.A it's a hustle bro like
people was rich off the pit and nobody
is above the bit uh [__] a pip your
mama like [__] a bit they mama like
it's almost like treasure hunting the
baby
you [__] around and get the right car
you might change what I'm saying this is
Rich off the bed bro like yeah but just
my advice just don't leave nothing in
your car
um
pay attention like you really can't
um it's gonna happen like eventually you
really can't not
um like get away from the bip like ain't
no telling who's beeping like I would
just like I think I was just telling my
boy uh oh shout out to Brian Sampson but
we're talking about going out there and
I was like yeah if we get a car it's
gonna have to leave the trunk open leave
all the windows down not even that just
do your [__] in your room bro no for
sure but I'm like just to not deal with
the broken window oh yeah it's more
about dealing with the broken window
yeah and then um two the [__] car uh
the window shops repair shops oh they're
just uh they're just racking it they're
running oh that'd be a great business
move to the Bay open up a window shop
open it up by the airport oh you're
eating bro yeah they're racking it in
bro for sure
are they so I the last time I went to
the city there was all the CVS's were
closed because of that I think it's uh
you could steal up to like nine yeah
they're still eight dollars yeah
it's wild San Francisco is a different
place is it like that in Oakland no okay
no what I just closed one of the
Walgreens is in um 34th because they
they've been tearing that up for years
but Oakland is not as bad as the
different mayor different police force
yeah different exactly and then um
like San Francisco like they just forgot
about their homeless like that [__] is
sad bro yeah that [__] is sad like that
[__] is like damn near um what a whole
Bay like California period is turning
into tent cities for sure L.A it's been
like I mean I always [__] up but the
thing about La is like it's not
concentrated anymore so I feel like you
go to San Francisco you'll see a lot of
homeless people but I feel like if you
drive to like I don't know Daily City or
something you're not going to see as
much as much right right if you're in
L.A no matter where you're at in L.A you
go to Sherman Oaks you go to [__]
Venice wherever you're at there's tents
bro right right and it's sad because
we're California like and then um not
even to get into hell of politics like
this but help me understand this bro
like
where do we get this money from to find
and help other countries when they're in
dire need but we can't do it for our
country bro I don't disagree with you
man
yeah like it's like wait hold on but
Flint's water's still dirty right like
what
it's crazy it's all geopolitical
[__] it's let me ask you a question
yeah
um you'll come on my podcast yeah all
right don't just say that because we're
on your [__] bro I'm gonna hold you too
and you're being chatting on me too bro
yeah bro this [__] let me tell y'all so
one time I don't know I hit you up look
bro what's your name
Cyrus one time we in LA right so uh no
no no so one time we're in L.A he oh
yeah blood man I'm at the reschedule I
got sick I'm like okay cool right I go
to the Freddie Gibb [__] right
who I see in the corner I'm shaking
their ass I wasn't shaking my ass
hey by the way if I go walk up that was
the day after no it wasn't it was the
day no it was the day it was it the same
day
same exact day so my boy Tash like bro
isn't that Kev right there I'm looking
you know I'm rolling the dice I'm like
oh it is I go walk over there I'm like
bro what's up he oh your little blood
yeah man I feel a little better like
yeah by the way by the way by the way
okay by the way I definitely was not
feeling good uh secondly uh-huh Freddy's
thing I wouldn't have missed
I'm one of my best friends in the world
I'm not gonna miss this [__] but I
definitely was not I was I was
definitely not feeling I had to cancel
two interviews that day okay you weren't
the only thing I canceled all right
yeah I was talking to Cyrus and then the
other the other thing is anytime I'd hit
you you'd be like you just tell me the
day I see I don't I don't like to
operate on that because I got to think
too much man I'll be like if you tell me
hey I'm gonna be out here the 14th
through the 17th how you doing Eric
where's Eric Eric just went outside with
this barking dog he just got decided to
bring the [__] work today
he just got this dog and decided to
bring it in like it's not gonna bark and
he's telling everyone don't worry it's
not gonna bite you like you just got the
dog how do you know she's a sweetheart
that's what he did she's a sweetheart
bro she won't bite you but the dog's
barking at me
I'm trying to see here oh wait I'm
looking no we already you said you're
not gonna miss it we're here yeah bro
yeah no I definitely I'm down yeah I
wanna uh I definitely gotta come through
man yeah that'd be dope as [__] and I
appreciate
um you know I appreciate the look like I
said you need to really dig into my
music career bro like I'm responsible
for a lot of these cats well that's
right like honestly like it's so hard
for me to keep up with everything and
the base [__] is so like
I try my best to be as engaged as
possible but there's a lot of [__] what
do you get your love from the day from
just I think just living growing up on
the west coast and then like as a little
kid my dad's favorite rapper was too
short so I was listening to [__] Too
Short in the clips Spice One all that
[__] and so like and I also I'm like a
student of the game so like I will see
like
the influence of like certain [__] you
know like and just be like damn the bay
really got so much sauce and just for
whatever reason always is just passed
over yeah or like just a little
disrespected or not necessary and like
you said it I do feel like there is a
lot of that with the bay where it is a
crabs in the barrel mentality with a lot
of artists out there right so um I just
had YG and tiger right they were in
Oakland right yeah West Oakland dog town
okay let's get this right is that where
they shot the video with the blast
record a different record no it was a
different record it was like a record
which is tiger and YG on there and uh I
think it was called going platinum and
uh you know they tapped in shout out
davo they tapped in I'll bring them out
there no beautiful day
um
a lot of people um enjoyed theyself you
know they were very cool they taking
pictures with the fans shaking hands
kissing babies and then bam
all these cats oh y'all dick Ryan White
genio y'all doing this y'all got them
[__] in Oakland and Blah Blah's like
[__] like right now that you know these
guys are Mega Stars there's been people
and females listening to these guys for
since they were in school and just like
yeah like the city's gonna be in the
music video is gonna get love like this
is like something to kind of help bro
why not show up and try to network yeah
and the people who was there it was
beautiful they bought all these cars out
um they really showed the culture you
get what I'm saying and then for our own
people to like just like hate on that
[__] that [__] was disgusting to me like
this make people not even want to come
[__] with y'all and y'all wonder why
we're not on or why we not in certain
positions and [__] like that because now
that they come they love the hospitality
we show them hell of a great time but
it's like now they gotta go back and
watch their names being tarnished on the
internet even though people don't give a
[__] about it but [__] not
necessary
if YG and tiger came to Phoenix and
tried a music video everybody'd be so
happy they'd be like this is amazing
yeah you feel me right right right right
right right but I mean but but also I
mean I get it like I think that like
like you said like I think that like
I feel like when you're kind of like not
on purposely maybe undervalued or
underappreciated in the grand culture of
California and Hip-Hop like you might
have a a a
what am I trying to say
uh not rock on your shoulder what's the
what's the saying I'm trying to say I
don't know I'm lost what is it
trip on your shoulder the [__]
um but yeah because I feel like a lot of
that kind of also happen when like Drake
did the motto right right for sure I
wish he would have put a barrier artist
on the remix right right yeah for sure
that would have been dope you know but
again like
it was it was a moment at that time
sneak or something just somebody yeah it
could have been 40. could have been
whoever I really wish that there would
have been a model remix because I think
the only remix there was was a tiger
remix
oh yeah which made no sense to me
because I'm like yo you got to put
somebody on for me so you're really into
the bay area like you know you kind of
yeah yeah for sure
hey whoever came out of Arizona like
doing the music
why is he laughing bro
he's from Arizona too I mean we had a
MC Magic
don't know who the [__] that is shout
out to MC Magic though so he's a Mexican
artist who's very popular he's a legend
he's a legend for sure shout out to MC
Magic uh we have he's the biggest
guy named futuristic who had like a
little independent run that was good he
did on Jimmy Fallon show Once
we had uh then there was like this wave
where Ludacris signed Willie North Pole
to dtp
the game sign juice who now goes by
Richie Evans the 50 Cent has some guys
well 50 signed a guy named hot rod hot
rod yeah hot rod had a record with Mary
J Blige called be easy but hot rod is
really from Sacramento oh he's not from
Arizona so he when he when he signed a G
Unit like he was living in Arizona at
the time he was a part of a crew called
the man up Squad and it was cool you
know but
I don't think we like really like he
still lives in Arizona but he wasn't
like an AZ guy right he was from Sac one
dot one guy he had that record body
marked up really North Pole that was
that's really North Pole who signed with
Luda put it he put an album out probably
the biggest deal we've ever had was
woolly North Pole put an album out
through Def Jam and dtp that I got I
actually got to go to the store and buy
okay okay which is like a big deal is he
still around like he's still I mean he's
I don't think he's making much music but
he's still around okay he's a legend you
know um this is one guy I just heard of
as of recently
um he was messing with slim 400 desert
Baby Desert baby I think he might be
like is Desert baby still incarcerated
yeah free desert baby okay and then uh
Riley you ever heard of Riley Riley's
Riley is my boy yeah boy Riley Riley
blood yeah I got a song with Riley blood
shout out Riley blood see I'm typing
yeah Rodney's a good guy yeah yeah and
like right now there's like Chris Coke
there's mercums Kylie there's uh who
else is popping [__] in AZ uh Jada
pink is though there's like a dope
bubbling scene right now outside
question
I'm talking to you I'm interviewing you
yeah but look why um why you think AZ
haven't had they shot very much a
crabbing the barrel mentality very much
so probably I mean it's terrible do you
support it though you're from Asia you
like to have the biggest figures I'm for
sure yeah I've had everybody come in
freestyle on my show I think that um
I think that with these smaller markets
sometimes it's very easy to get wrapped
up in pointing your finger at everybody
else as to why your [__] ain't doing
what you should be doing so I always
tell artists like hey man you got to
take a [__] in your own hands like you
got to build fan bases that are in the
independent of you having
I mean I hate to break it to everybody
but getting your [__] played on the
radio don't make a difference right
right
and I tell people that all the time
Instagram shout out don't mean [__]
either they don't mean nothing uh it's
like bro you need people to buy into you
you need to build that catalog you need
to formulate your sound you need to
figure out how you're going to turn five
fans to ten and 10 into 20 over and over
stop because a lot of times like I'll
get people like man [__] bootleg Kev he
ain't put me on his [__] and I'm like
bro like
I I always tell people just because
you're from Phoenix don't mean you just
get to come on my [__] right I gotta
just like be a fan of what you're doing
I gotta [__] see what you're doing
and I gotta be like oh [__] okay yeah
pull up and I've had a hell of people
from Arizona motion hella people but
it's just a matter of like I think with
a lot of those smaller markets that
tends to be the cases those are crab in
the barrel cities unfortunately because
there isn't nobody knows better we
haven't had somebody really pop to be
like oh that's how it's done all right
right you know what I mean and I think a
lot of the guys who end up making this
[__] work on a bigger scale kind of
leave for a little bit and I think
that's with anywhere you know sometimes
you got to get out of your your comfort
zone and I also think too that um
once somebody start getting a little bit
of like they turn their nose up for sure
yeah oh he switched up all right well
what do you mean
what are you saying like but yeah I
think I think Arizona's a definitely
crabbing the mentality uh it's getting
better and a lot of people are working
with each other now and it's definitely
um
you know because what Arizona I just
know it's Phoenix
uh Tucson so Tucson's an hour away I
know right uh we really don't
consider them the same
like Tucson and Phoenix there's two big
colleges that are like hardcore Rivals
so Tucson and Phoenix have a [__]
rivalry I'd rather [__] with Tucson
[__] than Phoenix [__]
I I feel you yeah I lost my virginity to
a Tucson [__] see in my dad's truck in
Tucson I met her in an MSN chat room
but the only thing is Tucson it's like
[__] desert is like country Tucson is
a Vibe it's just very small yeah
definitely there's definitely like
you're not gonna The Nightlife sucks
like the people from Tucson I like one
strip club like yeah and the strip
club's weird the last time I went it was
it was not a Vibe I just went oh no I
just when I went to Tucson
it's a bar town like yeah I mean I've
had fun in Tucson I mean like and like
you said you it's it's you could pull in
Tucson easy right right they're like oh
people are here that aren't from here
like oh look at you they'll get you some
EGS
what isn't that EG's is the name of the
drink they got
yeah it's called EG's yeah Tucson is its
own thing
it's its own thing man two Sean is a t
it's a good tweak but yeah you know all
the Arizona's like hardcore like you
know especially Tucson but so without
Tucson and Phoenix like where do y'all
go in AZ and we're not talking about the
tempees and [__] that's around Phoenix
like Mesa none of that like besides that
it's over with I mean you could go to
Flagstaff [__] Flagstaff who goes to
Flagstaff like what's in Flagstaff you
could snowboard uh there's Sedona which
is beautiful
go to Sedona and trip trip balls it's
like a bunch of spiritual vortexes and
[__] and let me show you sedona's
[__] beautiful so
okay where would Drake do a show at
besides Phoenix to Arizona Tucson
besides Tucson
oh okay it's all a bunch of red rocks
and [__] right right right no they're
nowhere else
maybe Flagstaff maybe at NAU maybe at
the college okay but now
Arizona is literally Phoenix right and
then a bunch of
just Tiny Places I mean two songs of
cool Tucson's cool it's not like a
[__] hole in the wall it's Phoenix
Tucson and nowhere else
there's Yuma there's the Grand Canyon
which I've never been to and I'm from
Arizona to your club but let's talk
about that sure whenever I want to come
have a drink and I want to come you feel
me to do the whole experience I've seen
cardi B you feel me James Harden like
what the [__] like I'm blue blood can I
come I'm trying to think the next time
I'm I think I'm gonna be there next
weekend
I think we have
we're working on a big booking next week
and I can't say but yeah next weekend
next week I'll be there Saturday between
you want to go to AZ tops
it's hot right now
how long is that drive it's like 10
hours 12 hours [__] that
ain't [__]
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our family at Odd Socks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
world ladies and gentlemen uh go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg cab or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right also
got a shout out to our family at King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a totor a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying and then you got
flavor I'm going to show you what it
looks like when it's stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms maybe you already know what
it is and if you go to kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout
half off at checkout 50 off if you go to
kingpom.com and use that promo code the
promo code is down below go run it up
try some of these flavors too man the
peach pineapple the Strawberry Shortcake
they just got so much going on there's
also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview
um so where do you want to take low
blood TV
um honestly
um that Joe Rogan back right so it's not
just about little Blood TV it's talking
meteors where we focus on low blood TV
is a show under talking it's one of the
shows it's one of the shows we also have
he say shishay Okay shout out to my
brother little goofy and my sis Haley
they have a dope ass show on our um
channel on our platform it's called he
say she say when y'all get a chance
tweak on it but I wanted Joe Rogan back
we want that job yeah we want it we want
it you can't come pay little blood you
got to pay talking media and we you want
somebody to come and just bag you out
for the company yeah so for you is it
because again we I feel like you're
gonna get to a point where you're gonna
have to hit the road we already do that
that's what I was gonna say because
there's I just saw you backstage it what
show were you backstage at uh Jean
Perico right yeah yeah yeah yeah uh yeah
um but I do feel like
and this is a conversation I'll be
having we just hit the road have you
seen gazi's podcast Studios he's
building yeah yeah for sure matter of
fact um shout out Ghazi I was just
having a hard conversation with gazi
about doing some business with him with
that yes for sure so I'm gonna start
doing like a episode a week out there
okay cool but I think that the there's
gonna be to like expand
unfortunately it's not a lot of people
going to the Bay unless they're going to
do something that's what I told I told
like I told Ghazi I said people are
coming to the Bay
and they got a itinerary so it's like
hard to squeeze in a two-hour long-form
conversation into that itinerary as
opposed to like
people living in L.A right New York
right right right right you know what
I'm saying have you noticed like have
you ran into that
issue where it's like [__] I could do an
interview with this person but I only
got 20 minutes or you know
um honestly
um
like in all places do to God bro like
but if you know me and people like
really like they people are really not
giving me like that like people changing
schedules to do my [__] like
um
or even just like access to certain
guests that you yeah so shout out Nano
shout out my brother Nano uh music you
ever heard of him who from uh Boston oh
Millie's yeah yeah Millie's my bad
um my brother Nano had called me like
hey bro you want to interview bro you
[__] with you you know I told him about
it like Yeah well yeah here in L.A we
drove right up knocked it up got you so
you'll do I'm traveling but I need the
boola calves you feel me I need the the
atoms like give me the game bro like I'm
a student of this [__] like y'all are
who I study like I pay attention to
y'all I watch y'all [__] I watched a
million dollars worth of games like I'm
I'm studying y'all and if
if y'all not giving us the game or y'all
not helping it's like it's no it's no
point it's like you feel me it's it's a
bagging and [__] for everybody for sure
like everybody and I hate The
Gatekeepers that keep the gate closed
like you know yeah yeah no I mean listen
I didn't even know there was a
gatekeeper thing in the podcast world
man that's a gatekeeper thing anywhere
bro come on you know how that [__] go
like everywhere right it's politics bro
people play and it's weird but like I
said it would have been Boosie of you it
wouldn't it wouldn't have costed you
nothing like or if you would have been
like nah [__] love and you know are you
talking to loresso not even bringing it
up like damn I [__] with Bloodshed like
I think he got a dope you feel me like
you couldn't have said nothing you get
what I'm saying like and by you just
giving a [__] his flowers that opened
up oh what you think you need it you
don't know he dope as [__] music and
they have you go tap in you feel me like
that type of [__] and when I mean by
Gatekeepers it's like
the uh drink Champs and you know the
household names right you guys are the
you know The Gatekeepers that's how I
look at it and and like I said it's it's
on you guys and I'm not saying just go
find some random [__] oh yeah
I'm gonna put you on my [__] no I see
you working I see you serious you
[__] around come on let's build let's
Network you get what I'm saying yeah I
think I think for you you're just gonna
have to hit the road a lot yeah and I'm
ready and we do that we do that because
I think I think the thing about like
like I said like
the tour I feel like Torah routing has
changed a lot as to where like there's
not as many rap tours as there used to
be there's a lot of people doing spot
dates there's a lot of people hopping on
bigger tours but like I feel like even
like five six seven years ago there was
just everybody would tour and I feel
like the touring should just kind of
slowed down and I just think the
opportunity to like sit down with a lot
of people in the bay
is gonna it's gonna kind of you're gonna
be kind of running a one a one leg race
initially so what you're gonna have to
do is
make the [__] pop move around do the
bass [__] if you got to go to La if you
got to go to Atlanta if you got to go
here you got to go here and then little
Blood TV becomes the destination okay to
where now it's like oh not if I'm going
to Cali we gotta go to the bathroom we
have to go sit down with oh it's a 45
minute flight it's a six hour drive so
now you're
amongst okay if I'm planning my press
run
I know I have to go to California and
not just go to and I think that's the
goal of what gazi's trying to do is like
have a whole
infrastructure of media Outlets
that is San Francisco based right right
towards like cool now when you come to
the Bay you can go do a little Blood TV
bootleg cab is going to be there uh and
then you know whatever new shows gazi
develops because we want to develop some
new new shows to populate that floor so
I think that's kind of the the bigger
picture is like I gotta get dishes super
hot
and now people gonna have to come right
right and that's and remind you we're
only in a year right 100 yeah I'm saying
so um you should do way more I would
love to see you do more [__] with
athletes because I think the Marshawn
Lynch is dope I was just like I was just
telling somebody I was like yo why is
the Marshawn Lynch done a podcast right
right that [__] we go quick Draymond
Green's running it up right right right
right right right running it up right
right well um you know be small films
man we families right yeah I just feel
like if he got on during the he could
just be football season if if Marshawn
Lynch were to go the I am athlete or
pivot route it'd be the biggest [__] in
sports
yeah I think it'd be crazy shout out to
Marshawn because he's like a
one-of-a-kind person yeah definitely
definitely definitely even like I was
like talking to RJ about I was like yo
why doesn't 40 do like drink Champs
before you be drunk right you know what
I'm saying boy he's the drunkest
[__] I know bro every time I see
40 he is sluricaned out you know what
I'm saying like I'm like bro imagine if
40 sat down with an artist once a week
and just they drank their wine because
you know he loves that wine right have
you done drink Champs yet like no I mean
I'm I almost uh so I was drink Champs
was supposed to do a network
um and I was supposed to sign with
Noriega as like because I announced I
was going to launch a podcast in
probably 2018 and Nori had hit me and
he's like don't do it yet I'm putting
this network together and I wanna I want
you to be one of the first guys we
signed ended up not working out I kind
of like sat on my hands waiting for it
to
whatever deal
to shake out
um that he was working on a I don't want
to say with who but he had like a couple
of people he was working on his Network
deal with
um didn't end up happening and I was
just like dude I'm trying to do my thing
like I'm gonna just do this [__] like I
got a studio I got like I got everything
I need you know what I mean so
um so yeah no but I'm real tight with
Nori that's my dog um but I haven't gone
to drink I mean I've been to episodes of
dream Champs off camera you know I've
hung out and it's a Vibe for sure it is
a it is a lot of energy
but I think if you don't I don't think
40's done drink Champs
or I don't know Matt could be wrong I
feel like that would that that's gonna
happen
I'm not sure but yeah man but not
definitely you're doing your thing
you're on the right path man appreciate
it appreciate it everything's high
quality
you know what I'm saying your team over
here is killing the production
appreciate it appreciate it so when you
hit the road you just take the the light
with you right no no we take our whole
[__] no but I mean like you're set
always has the light no matter what so
that's dope so you can just do that [__]
anyway yeah hell yeah hell yeah talk to
Media like a little Blood TV like hell
yeah definitely it's just you know like
you said marketing and branding and
we're just trying to keep we're trying
to be a household name we're not trying
we're going to be I don't believe in
corner crime or nothing like that I
believe in manifest and [__] so if I
just keep speaking on this [__] and
manifesting like I manifested this yeah
I think you guys have such a dope like I
feel like you know I try to have the um
the Stockton guys on my show I had a GB
from Modesto yeah
I had another kid from Modesto that I
saw at the Russell's house freestyle and
I just invited him up to Freestyle what
was that kid's name he's 16. he came up
here with his dad oh yeah he's raw he
got dreads fire yeah yeah he's raw as
[__] yeah I know you talking about but I
think that like there's so much going on
just in Northern California that like
it's nice that you have a dope platform
to like
throw some of them alley Hoops too for
sure because I think I think dizzler
does a good job with this for sure [__]
care bro what am I saying me with the
the Freddie Gibbs [__] bro so don't just
say for sure and you know I'm talking
about alley Hoops bro because I'm a
ditch you you weren't the only person I
canceled that day yeah I forget who else
it was I'm the only person that caught
you
I mean I wasn't not sick
I was I wasn't I wasn't no he has drank
in his head [__] these [__] that
ain't sick
hey man it was I had to make sure I knew
what kind of night it was going to be I
had to get my rest
I had to get my rest yeah I knew it was
going to be a nightlife I need them
alley hoops man and I throw you some
alleys too man now yeah I got to come
out there that's crazy Mozzy was going
to come with me too right now
he's out finally what was it about a
year a little under a year was it yeah
yeah he was gonna come I said nah I
can't hater hey there's a reason why I
have that plaque there yeah it's on
camera I said let me go Philly my first
man let me go see I love my that's my
brother man he's a great guy man I'm
happy definitely definitely happy he's
home man I appreciate you pulling up uh
what's the IG what's the uh my personal
IG third world low blood 3rd
w-o-r-l-d-l-i-l-b-l-o-d that's if you
want some dope ass music you feel me
you're gonna follow that page boom
little Blood TV it's my podcast page
l-i-l-b-l-o-o-d TV that's the podcast
page Tiger Media
t-h-a-k-u-r-m-e-d-i-a that's where you
get all of he says she says the
everything you need to know about low
blood whatever go to talker media you
tap in with them for management whatever
the case you need me to do talker media
who Bert Jones I got a question before
we leave
okay so we don't charge people right for
podcasters we've never done that we be
turning down money and [__] I've never
taken money yeah like is that a thing
like on from from the airport okay now I
don't think it's a thing
amongst like the platforms that are
respectable okay okay cool there are
definitely platforms that are uh I don't
think have high integrity okay okay my
thing is if my cosine's worth like like
if I if you could pay me for my cosign
what's my co-sign Worth right right it's
like you know what I'm saying right
right you know I turned down a lot of
money
like a lot of money we do too we don't
you feel me I think people offer me
thousands of dollars but it'll be a
different I'll click on the links
no what is it like it's a sponsor
sponsorship that's different oh yeah
well we sponsored up over here right
right shout out to hardine shout out to
King Kong shout out to Bluetooth Odd
Socks we got my Odd Socks right there
all right LRG clothing that's right who
else is sponsoring the podcast these
days my bookie if you want to gamble
yeah I mean listen y'all watch the
commercials you know right right no I'll
take the sponsorship but you can't pay
me to get on my [__] right right right
right right yeah cause we don't do that
either I'll do favors like if somebody I
know hits me and I respect them and
they're like hey I just signed this kid
he's dope can he come on the show I'd be
like Kenny Freestyle right right A lot
of times it's like the more
up-and-coming like raw talent I have
them do the freestyle thing okay okay
okay because it doesn't you know the
interview might not make sense okay okay
but I'll do favors right right but I
won't I won't um I haven't taken money
now right I figure if that's the
difference listen there was a small
point in time though where I was on a
terrible gambling binge
I was down like 30k and I remember
telling my boy David I said man I might
just start taking somebody
I didn't do it I didn't do it it's the
only time I thought about it right the
New York Jets beat the Bengals in like
week seven with Mike White as the
starting quarterback and I lost like 15
grand and I was like
yeah gambling is bad
yeah thank God it's not legal and well
look it doesn't matter we're actually
gambling isn't terrible if you go to my
bookie and use the promo code bootleg
and you sign up and uh
yeah I'm a user you know
Nano he's a [__] Gambler just gotta
love it I don't know well anyway I
appreciate you pulling up man I
appreciate that you came boom I
appreciate y'all watching another
interview brought to you by our good
Folks at hardean now listen y'all when
you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell him to take you to hard
Dean the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
you'll see period anywhere let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you'll get the best experience the best
customer service the best bud tenders
you walk in the hard Dean and that [__]
just smells amazing they got their own
[__] scent literally you get into my
car I got a bottle of it my car smells
like Harding because it's just the best
[__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you'll pull up tell
them I sent you they're gonna take care
of you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hardine all right you gotta
go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love